it's
for
[Music]
sh
for for
[Music]
can't take that it's very soft
watch on the 10
P going to
[Music]
pass shoulder
see it's already
there sof you go past the elbow drops on
side you po the elbows on the other side
see okay that's the opening all I need
right
here
elbow elbow the
other side
t
on you're going past my
elbow you see you tank on you past my
elbow
Bo
it soft
so I let you keep coming
[Music]
in there a b the opening is there so I
go here and you let go the opening St
this
elbows
elbow the throw is not
on this hand that's not good
I
clear the Ed me right here you
see you so you don't want to pull this I
don't want to pull
that you're going to end up in tension
on okay if they extend the arm
themselves like Taylor did then I take
it
okay capture that
like
go capture it here adhesion on the elbow
that's why you guys are like why the
am I going so high okay cuz I can
feel you like grab p and there and you
leave it and you throw the whole
thing let
go okay one capture
it the whole thing
goes Bo
[Music]
Capt El P
Capt okay all right so we're talking
about the EDI NGA portion of the throw
and a lot of people think EDI n is bend
them backwards at an angle enough that
you can just force them down
your Superior leverage and as a result
this often pulls people that's how you
see that a lot and you see and then they
come in and they do
that what I was doing was something
different okay so I use the turn to get
my elbow behind him my elbow's behind
and I don't pull this okay I just need
that stay there please I just need this
that's enough for all the e nugget teni
nugget all of that and that's all you
should expect combatively so if we're
here and we're fighting you see I get
that was all I need that's what you'll
see in Judo for example you're not going
to see that you've been someone like all
this far and then you came in with your
Technique you just need a tilt okay
so we're dealing with that there he is
okay just stay there don't
worry and uh we're going to look at this
arm okay so on the upper
body my
head here at the
shoulder uh and tricep area walk around
camera too my tri my shoulder at the
tricep area is in an
adhesion so I can do
this okay
and you add the surface to it so now I
have my head on his shoulder by shoulder
on his
tricep and I add the upper arm it's
across his chest it's on the side of his
neck and all that is moving him this
way which is the adhesion so I'm not
going to tighten it I'm not trying to do
a coted I just make contact
and this will
adhere so with that
adhesion I
bring him this way this way so that's
what's happening on the upper
body I'll take it
off on the EDI which is the X
PN you're going to have
contact on the rib cage
and the
hip and so I'll take off the upper body
and I adhere there and you move
him okay so that is all
happening in the technique so as I come
around and I start to move him this
way and I start to assist that movement
with my lower
body he will
tilt so he's here like that and I tilt
him and then I do
this his foot will come up and his head
will go
down okay
here that's all you need you come in you
make contact you want the contact you
keep entering across that tilt I'm not
going to do it on him but you keep
entering across that tilt I'm going to
look at this hip now in the x pattern
but we know I'm
rotating okay as we
rotate it'll load this kosi and that is
the ex
padon going this
way I'm
here and I'm hitting
here so you're bringing him
around which she's going to
tilt then there's a
fulcrum and then there's an obstruction
to his abil AB ility to step back
underneath him okay that is the
technique so without the throw
but kind of the throw okay you don't
don't try
to B him that's just that's how
my teacher did it too but it's not right